if you have tried the new fortnight
limited time event then you'll know that
it's not the easiest task to get that
Golden Glove now I can't tell you how to
get it every time but I can give you
some hints that I found helped me get
the Infinity Gauntlet much more often
the Gorner will spawn inside the preset
circle when you spawn on the map the
objective now is to get as much airtime
as possible
ride the bus to the end of the circle
then jump to pour your shoot and make it
to the middle of the circle as fast as
possible you'll see plenty of people
around you now your objective is to get
just below them but not so low that you
can't do a little skydive at the end you
may have to tap your shoot button again
again to just get a few more feet below
the guy next to you but while being as
low as possible while also having as
much airtime as possible gives you the
best shot at getting the Infinity
Gauntlet you'll hear a noise somewhere
around the two-minute mark the gauntlet
will follow soon after so keep your ears
and eyes open as soon as you hear a
sonic boom you should be able to see the
infinity corner flying in now is the
time to skydive hopefully because you're
in the middle of the circle you'll be in
a good position to get close to the
comet the comet flies fast so aim in
front of it then when you've got the
angle just right point down fall as fast
as possible then your glider should be
able to take you the rest of the way now
this won't work every time since
everyone's their hands on the glove but
it definitely gives you a good fighting
chance you could do extra things like
landing on trees and buildings to drop
down faster too so in summary staying
the sky as long as you can get to the
middle be the lowest parachute to
possible wait for the 2 minute ish mark
fly fast and aim ahead of the comet then
if you're on PC gets the gauntlet and
spam eat as fast as possible if you
still have no luck but still want to
check out Fanus then we have a full
victory royale gameplay video on our
youtube channel so go check that out and
for more for night fun times make sure
you subscribe to gamespot.com
[Applause]